[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on 15th of
September I'm Cindy Yu the broadcast
editor of The Spectator
coming up on the show
the queen is lying in state in
Westminster hall yesterday she was taken
there by procession from Buckingham
Palace and now a queue of mourners are
lining the South Bank of the Thames to
see her coffin I'll speak to James
Forsyth Katie bulls and Alexander larman
about the week since the Queen's death
the world's media has come to London to
cover the event but it seems like some
of our friends in America don't quite
get it Douglas Murray will be on the
show to explain why
Ukraine meanwhile is retaking its land
from Russia oh Matthews and Mike Martin
will join us to discuss the recent
counter-offensive and whether Putin's
position in the Kremlin is in danger
and finally who are the Sweden Democrats
they've been dubbed far right by much of
the English language media but they may
well be heading into Sweden's next
government
I'll be joined by Paulina neuding and
James Savage
before we get going we've got a special
offer for spectator TV viewers for just
one pound you can get 10 weeks of the
magazine imprint deliver straight to
your door and online go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash flashsale
to sign up and why not subscribe to our
YouTube channel click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
the queen will spend the next few days
lying in state in Westminster Hall what
is the last week of morning look like
who has been invited to Monday's funeral
and what will be the big political
issues facing the government when
politics resumes I'm joined Now by
political team James rosyth and Katie
pools as well as Alexander larman author
of the crown in crisis and the literary
editor of the spectators World Edition
Alexander larman Katie and James welcome
to spectator TV now Alexander as we're
recording outside of the Westminster
offices of The Spectator we've got a
miles long queue of members of the
public waiting to see the queen lying in
stage and that's going to be happening
for the next few days until her funeral
on Monday to start with what has struck
you about this morning period that we
have seen over over the last week um
what are some of the reflections that
you've had
or just dealing immediately with the
queue it was interesting because
somebody said that essentially it was
like pilgrimage and I think that's a
very good way of putting it because I
think what people are doing is their
inconveniencing themselves away but they
wouldn't usually be doing so I mean you
hear these stories about 10 Mile cues
people sleeping in the rain outside and
there's obviously a real personal
inconvenience to doing it but I think
the people see this as something far
greater than themselves what's
fascinating is that in 2022 we're
constantly being told that we are
solipsistic we don't have any wider
understanding of the world other than
ourselves and that the only
communication we have with others is
social media but in fact what we are
seeing in real life in this queue it's a
coming together of people from a
completely different walks of life all
of them are united by desire to pay
homage to the queen and that's something
quite remarkable because I think there's
been so much speculation about what's
going to happen when she dies a lot of
the speculation I think is inhibited
around the idea that people are going to
be you know grief stricken and Mourning
which I think has been true I mean I
think that the general sense has been
that of grief but I think over and above
grief is also coming together in a
shared National interest and in fact
it's very interesting to compare this to
Diana's death nearly 25 years ago
because that was very much about public
hysteria and grief and about something
we looked into almost a frenzy by the by
the media who'd tormented and pursued
her this is something different because
this isn't the death of a young woman
who's lived behind two young children
this is something I think greater and
more symbolic and I think that we've
actually seen generally speaking most
public institutions at their best are
Center Parks we've seen Parliament come
together and we've seen people you know
from Kirsten to Boris Johnson May
perhaps their best public speeches about
this we've seen people respond by and
large in a steady and measured way and
now I think in this extraordinary
spectacle of people queuing to pay their
respects we are seeing I think the
spirit of how it was when Winston
Churchill died all over again
um and what have you made of how Charles
has dealt with his first week as being
King
welcome to pity for King Charles is that
the um that embarrassment about his pen
not working geography has went viral has
gone viral has been very embarrassing
for him as over Shadows well I think
he's been doing it in a much quieter and
more steady way because obviously he has
wanted to be king for decades he has
been waiting for this since middle age
he's been anticipating what's going to
happen but I think the Southerner so it
must have taken him by surprise just
took all of us by surprise I mean nobody
could have imagined on Tuesday when the
queen was received I should be dead by
you know Thursday so he must obviously
in addition of course to having any kind
of but the usual grief for the sun feels
when his father dies he must have felt a
sense that he hasn't been fully able to
deal with everything that he's doing so
while I think it's far too early to have
any sense of what King Charles is going
to be like
I I would hope that what we've seen so
far has been a mixture of the private
man who is I'm sure irritable and I'm
sure of stressed but also the public
figure who can make speeches which
affect people and his first protocols
for nation I thought was very very good
I mean ending with Hamlet was a nice
touch because it nodded his own interest
in theater and he obviously brings in
The Shakespearean overtones but it's
also very effective
now James on Monday we will be expecting
the Queen's funeral to be attended by
um well almost all world leaders have
been invited and we think that quite a
lot of them are going to be turning up
but this could be a diplomatic Minefield
couldn't it because Joe Biden's already
insisted on his own presidential car and
today there's been confusion about
whether or not the president of China
has been invited
um it's a difficult time for the foreign
office
yeah obviously if you gather this many
heads of state in one place there are
going to be protocol issues you know who
gets this who gets that and but I think
that what you will see is that a lot of
these things will be smoothed over
before the event happens I think the
China thing that actually reflects a
broader question about uh the new
government and where it wants to stand
on on on the China question and and how
far that applies I think you will also
see though that there will be uh as
there often was at International Summits
where where the Queen's own presence uh
actually acts as a kind of restraint on
leaders Behavior I think it was one of
the notable things about uh the G7 in
Cornwall some of the more fraught
Commonwealth Summits of the Queen's
Reign that that her presence does act as
a kind of bomb in terms of keeping uh
world leaders behavior in check
um and it does seem like she transcends
not just domestic politics but global
politics as well I'm Alexander you
mentioned Center Parks earlier um I I
just wanted to touch on some of the um I
think unexpected reactions we've seen
from some corporate headquarters
um but also you know in terms of
branding and Paddington has been
mentioned almost as much as King Charles
III it seems in the last week um you've
written about this what do you make of
the reaction
the association of Paddington Bear the
Grim Reaper was not one I was expecting
I think it's fair to say and I think
that Michael Bond who created Paddington
would be surprised at what's happened as
well it should also be noted though that
the sketch which the queen appeared in
with Paddington at the Platinum Jubilee
was incredibly affecting because there's
a sense even though she's very Lively
and very vibrant in it it was also a
sense that her public life was drawing
to an end and when Paddington voiced by
Ben Wishaw says thank you your majesty
for everything I think that was a very
simple very moving sentiment but now a
lot of people are echoing but to return
to the idea of corporate branding it's
an incredibly difficult thing to get
right because if you don't go far enough
you'll be accused of insensitivity if
you go too far as centerparks have done
you will be accused of getting it so
badly wrong you actually end up damaging
your brand and I think there were some
companies have got it wrong is that
their Instinct has been shut everything
down you know let's go let's go
overboard let's have you know as many
tributes as we possibly can we do not
want to be accused of being irreverent
in any way but then if you look at
Prince Philip's death there was a real
sense back then where people got bored
with the coverage for they got aboard
what they often felt just vote on
hagiography and so once I think I would
worry about if I was in charge of a
major company's branding right now is
how far can I draw a line between being
reverential understanding how much this
means to people but also I mean putting
it quite simply keeping it business as
usual because I mean I'll do that on
Monday for the Queen's funeral the
entire country is going to grind to a
standstill there's a real sense that
it's gone a bit too far I mean there's a
real sense that I mean if he wants to go
and see a doctor that day you won't be
able to if you wanted to go to basically
anything that is a necessity of life
it's going to be far far worse than your
average bank holiday because everything
it's going to shut down so I think for
what the worry is going to be is that
especially by the middle of next week if
there's still a dragging sense of this
not been quite resolved people are going
to start taking against this Spirit of
coming together in the spirit of respect
so people are actually going to get
bored of it
well Katie let me bring you in here
because James has written in his
political column for The Spectator this
week about how politics is also one of
those things that's uh on pause looking
ahead to next week what are the issues
that are going to come flooding back
when we hit the resume button
I think there is a sense that things
will come back quite quickly in terms of
government business of course politics
have been suspended in the sense that
MPS have not been sitting where MPS have
been speaking in Parliament it has been
tributes to the queen
um and therefore we're going to see a
switch whereas after the Queen's funeral
I think we expect the new prime minister
Liz trust to fly to New York for a
international summer her first is prime
minister and then later in the week we
are expecting this mini budget now we
got to agree on what exactly we called
it um given if you were to describe it
as certain things you'd expect to have
an obr forecast and we're not expecting
that but this would be the chance the
Quasi quad Tang
um along with Liz truss um ultimately
bringing into effect
um those pledges that there's trust made
during her leadership campaign when it
comes to reversing the National
Insurance hike preventing the planned
Corporation hype from coming into effect
and we expect some more scrutiny because
we haven't had much scrutiny since Liz
trust has entered 10 Downing Street and
that's in part because obviously the
situation uh regarding the queen King
Charles III but also because when Liz
truss was inveing her plans including
for example the emergency relief so this
idea of freezing the price for two years
when it comes to energy and there were
no specific figures of what this could
cost they say this is because the price
is fluctuating too much it's hard to do
but you still couldn't imagine a
situation where you have different
forecast or scenarios that can be
discussed depending on what the price
does and then also the manner in which
this trust dresser has which I think
that session will always be remembered
now for the note she was passed from
Nadine zahori which had the news about
the queen in it as opposed to what she
was saying on energy and but no matter
what she did that meant that you
couldn't uh you know directly question
her in the way you would if it was a
ministerial statement and it's just
adding to the sense that will we have a
chance next week to really see some of
the potential figures will they continue
to say that is too hard to do
um and I think quite quickly that almost
the period where people haven't been
querying to the way that you would have
expected otherwise for what seems to be
one of the on energy one of the biggest
state interventions
um if we're looking at the figures we
expect it to cost I think quite quickly
we are now going to have lots of
questions about that about how it's
going to be funded and about how the
markets will respond
and James one round that has been
brewing in the background even through
this week is the summary sacking of Tom
scholar who was until last week the
permanent secretary at the treasury tell
us about that and why it's caused such a
stink in some quarters of Whitehall I
think the reason it's caused such a
stink is that Tom scholar was was sacked
in his first meeting with the chancellor
with immediate effect I think this
causes uh eyebrows to raise for two
reasons one is it is not unusual for uh
new secretaries of states or or uh to to
to to move on their permanent secretary
but it's normally done after a period of
time they say look I've tried working
with this person it's the relationship
isn't working out we need someone
different to sack someone on day one
before you've even started working with
them you know I I think I think does uh
politicize things more than it happened
in the past and then I mean the second
thing is as you say Cindy is that it's
happened with immediate effect there is
no gen transition here there is a there
is a straight away you're you're out and
I think that that that that has caused
uh unease because of because again it
adds to his sense that this is almost
like a spoil system you know Liz trust
has won the Tour of leadership so she
now is going to change the permanent
Secretary of the treasure now number 10
are Keen to stress that this is not
going to be part of some wider change in
the in the Civil Service
um but I think there is there are
concerns I think also I think a lot of
the the retired mandarins feel that
Simon case is the cabinet secretary you
know has not done enough to you know
very young take on that job and they
feel he's not done enough in his tenure
to uh
defend the Civil Service in in all the
various issues of the Boris Johnson yes
and they've and and they think that this
suggests that things are going to carry
on down down the same path I think that
I think the real challenge here is
if we aren't going to have a different
form of those others and a different
form of relationship between civil
service and the government of the day
which may well be a good idea I think we
should debate that openly and in public
rather than all of these things
happening almost by stealth
well also because to list trust and
quasiquarters agenda having a
functioning treasury is very very
important or at least an effective
treasury I guess they don't want it to
be a business as usual at that
department and Katie time is fast
running out for all of these big plans
because of the problems that are
building up there's talk about the
October recess parliamentary recess
being shortened so that people come back
earlier from party conferences in order
to sort these problems out is that going
to happen so we expect the recess period
to be shortened in terms of what that
means for various conferences the
suggestion so far is it won't affect the
duration of the labor conference or the
Conservative Party Conference they will
go ahead as planned there's been some
reports saying oh we might change the
mood the tone it could be a more somber
event
um but I I don't think anything final
really has been taken decision wise and
that and actually these events could go
on pretty much as you would have
expected them to otherwise I think is
where things are leaning towards at the
moment but as you you say is cutting the
recess period short because there's been
so many so few sitting days already and
this is why they're having to put the
fiscal event in for next week before the
labor conference takes place
um and then there's also other plans to
push through and I think just going back
to the point about Tom scholar you have
a situation where Liz truss and quasi
quattang were talking a lot uh during
the Leisure contest about
um getting rid of the treasury Orthodoxy
and I think axing Tom scholar is
probably the clearest sign that they
actually mean to do it but as you say
um the time in Parliament from
musgriction as to what that means is
going to be needed to see how this is
really all going to play out
Katie and James thanks for joining
spectator TV and earlier Alexander
larman
once again we've got a special offer for
spectator TV viewers for just one pound
you can get 10 weeks of the magazine in
print deliver straight to your door and
online go to spectator.co.uk forward
slash sale to sign up
Douglas Murray writing his column this
week that a monarchy is good for
politics in America he says they're
lumbered with political dynasties after
all like the clintons or the bushes
while in Britain a hereditary monitor
key gets that out of our Collective
system to explain Douglas joins me now
Douglas Murray welcome to spectator TV
now to start with we in the UK are going
through 10 days of mourning but it
doesn't seem like it's something that
has been well received across the world
well actually it has been well received
across much of the world except in
America by certain parts uh of the
American commentary act can you tell us
about what that's been like
yes the um the American public and
American officials have been enormously
sympathetic and expressed their
um their deep sadness and and you know
and their the feelings of of kinship
with the British people as as we go
through this period of national mourning
so that on one level it's it's it's you
know dignified respectful and and and an
expression of friendship as well as
sorrow
but uh there have been sections of the
American Media the American Press in
particular who just seem not and bits of
American Academia uh who seem not to be
able to keep their mouths closed for
even a day let alone 10 uh to show
respect uh for an ally uh within hours
of hamasi's death the New York Times ran
a hit piece about her uh accusing her of
being connected to the crimes of
colonialism
um which showed not only an unbelievable
historical ignorance but a
constitutional ignorance of the way in
which United Kingdom is set up that was
quite staggering and then in the uh days
and hours that followed that that just
got worse more and more people jumped
onto that bandwagon uh the New York
Times even holding
um a British writers uh you know radical
left and anti-monarchists to attack
Britain and attack the queen
they then the America the American
broadcast media like CNN and MSNBC
decided that that the period immediately
after the Monarch's death was the
perfect moment to start talking about
slavery again as if the American Media
doesn't talk about slavery all the time
and as if Queen Elizabeth II had any
connection to it
um so there was this sort of it wasn't
just ignorance it was malevolence in the
air and you can see that as being um to
do with a late Majesty which I don't
think it does all you can see it to do
as having to do with just the
extraordinary
monomaniacal and uh really malevolent
way in which everything is now looked at
uh in America always through these same
lenses as I said in my most recent book
always through these same lenses of
racism colonialism slavery as if we've
never talked about them ever before for
and this is the ideal time to do so
you write in your column that people
have a problem with us and and privilege
ironic when it comes from the American
quarters because to tell us about that
well yes I mean the the point to do with
the malevolence of the media is a
specific problem of modern America and
that's come from people who just hate
Britain basically are very racist
against the British are you know very
malevolent about our history uh and just
you know Guided by a horrible animus
against us but there is another type of
criticism that has come up in the last
week which is from a more friendly
quarter as it were from people who who
you know feel feel uh kinship with
Britain and I've heard this a couple of
times and I've sort of thrown my own um
uh Poppins into this debate a bit in
America in recent days which is that a
number of people said to me well there's
a problem with the monarchy which is it
it it's it seems to be the epitome of
unearned privilege and I've I've rather
enjoyed countering this point actually
in recent days because I keep saying to
people well first of all you know that
suggests that unearned privilege is
something which is unheard of In America
which is a hard position to hold
um and and and secondly it actually
misses something very important and as I
say my column and spectator this week
one of the remarkable things of the
constitutional monarchy is that our our
national the inevitable National
obsession with dynasties is focused on
one Dynasty and that one that's lasted
of course More Than A Thousand Years the
institution of the monarchy
um and and to a great extent this is a a
political interest but it's also to do
with an inevitable human biological
interest which is our interests in
watching genes play out are interest in
watching generation after generation of
a family where are the black sheep where
are the where are the bad eggs who are
the people who really are the the
inheritors of great um figures of the
past and much more you know who's got
her her side of the family more who's
got his side of the family more these
are sort of interesting conversations we
all have in our lives with about friends
and Friends children and so on but
nationally that Obsession focuses solely
on the institution of monarchy and we
don't have as a result uh political
dynasties or dynasties As Americans
would put it we don't have that we we
have a little bit of it uh on the
political left interestingly enough the
Ben and the family you might say Harriet
Harman of the pakenhams uh you might say
uh the middle a little bit of
milibandian and of course rather
remarkably a little bit of hereditary
cynicism which is a quite amazing and
unforeseeable
um uh hereditary line in politics that
one is international that power family
and that one's gone internationally
exactly who would have predicted that 30
years ago
um but you know the
um we don't have political identities
nobody's obsessed in Britain with
whether or not John Major's children are
going to come back and save us or you
know whether the Blairs are going to run
for office again whereas in America
politics is very dominated by a few
dynasties people are obsessed with it
and you don't have you know you can go
back to the founding and the 19th
century in America you could be Adams
Dynasty in American politics that you
can you can look at the the Roosevelts
for instance uh becoming more up to date
the Kennedys uh even more up to date
look at the way in which over the last
25 years it's looked at times as if the
presidency is simply going to rotate
between the Clinton family and the Bush
family uh you know a a look at the way
in which people wonder whether Michelle
Obama is going to run for office is
Chelsea Clinton going to run at some
point are the bushes going to offer us
up a new generation of talent
um and even though even the disruptors
in American politics Donald Trump is Don
Jr going to run you know think of this
in British terms and it seems absurd you
know
um are the Johnson children being lined
up for political office I would think
not
um uh so so as I say in the piece one of
the many many things that constitutional
monarchy does that is so good is it it
actually detoxifies the the political
Arena from having hereditary politics
hereditary electoral politics and you
know as well as providing us with
constitutional order and much much more
I think this is a little noted but
important role that the monarchy
provides it does seem like such an
extraordinary and strong pattern in
American politics now you've already
mentioned this human desire obsession
with seeing how genes play out but do
you think there's something else here
that means that America is so prone to
these dynasties you know what's going on
you know this is no longer a coincidence
yes that's right well there are some
explanations you could sit there for
instance running for the top job in
America means you've got to be able to
bundle a lot of money you've got to have
a lot of connections nationally across
all the states and much more and I
suppose you could argue that a sort of
that what we're really talking about and
this is what one American commentator
said to me the other day is maybe we're
talking about celebrity really in order
to run for office in America you need to
be famous you know Dr Oz is a good
example at the moment you know if you're
big on television uh with Donald Trump
you can become big in politics now that
there is something in that but that
doesn't explain the dynasties other than
that they are well placed to bundle
money and so on but I think there is
something else I think there is a sense
that and this is a very
anti-meritocratic sense but I think
there has been a sense that some people
know how to rule now again in Britain we
get that out of the way with the house
of Windsor
uh in America you you just have this
sort of you know this this sense always
that there are some people who know how
to do it how would X know how to do it
they've never been near office whereas
if people have been near office somehow
they might be pretty naturally
um knowledgeable about how to run the
country I I do think it's an odd
Temptation it's an odd inclination it's
very anti-meritocratic it's certainly
um anti-American and yet it's holy
American so uh yes I I've been pointing
out to people this week that if they um
if they if if they don't if if they
don't understand what Britain is going
through at the moment and don't
understand the depths of feeling that
might not be the fault of the monarchy
or the fault of the British public it
might be their fault and they should
look at it more well just very finely
Douglas how has that gone down when you
say that on American Media
you know a mixed a mixed bag
um I haven't yet had an encounter with
my friend Andrew Roberts has with an
entirely hostile interviewer as such as
he had on CNN the other day when um the
interviewer just seemed to want to rip
into Britain's uh history and Legacy and
it was left to Andrew to have to be
shouted over by the presenter as Andrew
was trying to present facts and the
presenter started saying you know this
is not a propaganda Channel
quite hard to hear a CNN presenter
saying that actually but with a straight
face
um and Andrew Roberts of course had to
point out that if the Americans were
going to start attacking her late
Majesty for the for the crimes of
slavery they should remember that it was
her very distant answers to George III
who signed the anti-slavery act in 1807
um many decades before America had a
civil war and had to kill 600 000 of
their own citizens in order to do away
with vile trade Britain did away with it
peacefully and then policed the high
seas for decades at enormous National
costs so I'm afraid as I say sorry to
return to where I started what we see in
the American some of the American as I
say responds to the death of the queen
has been just an alarming historical
ignorance but driven by an alarming
present day animus and I think that
we've seen who our friends are in
America across the aisle but we've also
seen particularly American Media who's
some really vitriolic enemies of Britain
are well Douglas you are always one
Pokemon spectator TV thank you so much
Ukraine has launched an effective
counter-offensive against Russia in the
last few weeks winning thousands of
square miles back from Putin's Army so
what exactly is happening on the front
line I'm joined Now by spectator
contributor Emma Matthews who writes in
this week's magazine about the ultra
right-wing nationalist who would be
likely to take over from Putin if he
were removed from power and Mike Martin
a former British Army soldier and the
author of why we fight
so oh Matthews and Mike Martin thank you
for coming on to spectator TV now Mike
tell us about the latest in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine because it does
sound like Ukraine's uh fighting back
and quite effectively over the last week
or so
yeah thanks Cindy it's it's actually a
really significant moment
um so over the last five or six days or
so the ukrainians have taken about 9 000
square kilometers of territory liberated
I should say
um from the Russian occupying forces and
in that area of the country in Hakeem in
the Northeast they've pushed the
Russians right back to the border and
quite significantly they've captured a
couple of major Logistics hubs and
Logistics routes that Supply the Russian
forces in not just in that northeastern
part of the country but also in the
donbass in the East where we had all
those big battles a couple of months ago
so this is a huge setback for the
Russian forces both militarily but I
think perhaps more importantly
psychologically because it's it's really
really created some ripples both within
the military and also within Moscow and
have they managed to do this because it
has been six months in the war so far
you know they're just better than right
um over the last couple of months
they've been building up and signaling
that they're going to be launching this
big offensive in the South and her son
um and that's you know a really
important area that the ukrainians need
to take back because it's it's on the
way to Crimea and Crimea is the the most
important part of Ukraine for Russia you
know that's the last bit that they want
to lose it's their strategic center of
gravity and because the ukrainians have
been signaling in that direction and
then about a month ago they launched
this curse on offensive that's quite
well covered in our media
um the Russians rushed loads of troops
down into her son and they stripped them
out from places like the donbass but
also in haki where we've seen this
offensive and so those thinned out
Russian lines basically the ukrainians
just punched through them and then had
very very fast mechanized forces
um so infantry on on Fast vehicles that
basically went behind through the
Russian lines and then took out the
logistics dance that I've just spoken
about and that caused the Russian lines
to collapse so actually the ukrainians
didn't need to fight every last Russian
soldier they just collapsed their
Logistics and they come under control
and then in in loads of places the
Russians just turned and ran away and
abandoned all of their equipment
oh and in The Wider scheme of things
what does this mean for the war because
it's actually optimistic to think that
this is going to be in the last few
months of the war will Russia you know
surrender
well there's actually two different
um planes on which this war actually is
being fought one of them is actually the
reality on the ground which Mike has
actually described very well and
accurately I mean and then there's the
public perception in Moscow and um
frankly
um there has been you know a certain
amount of bickering on various uh TV and
Kremlin and TV talk shows and so on
about who is to blame and so on but in
this ground scheme of things the Kremlin
is actually taking a really interesting
line
um and that is you know that the war
basically doesn't exist
so last week Vladimir Putin gave a uh a
40-minute very boring speech on
economics to the Vladivostok you know
Far Far Eastern forum and Vladivostok
and that in its in and of itself is
important that he actually decided the
most important thing he could talk about
was economics for 40 minutes and didn't
mention War once
um and he obliquely referred to sort of
difficulties and new situations and so
on but like but also more importantly
not a single word about sort of
patriotism
so um I think actually the it's it's
very significant that Kremlin actually
has sort of decided to play this down
enormously and at the beginning I mean
there's various you know rumors flare up
from time to time that Putin needs to
announce a full mobilization uh that's
the only way he's going to win this war
but I'm sure I mean Mike is better
qualified to talk to me to talk than I
am about this but I mean mobilization
doesn't really help Putin on the ground
he doesn't really need more untrained
people furthermore as we know from
various sort of military bloggers a lot
of the uh tactical battalions in every
division that are so the training
battalions in every division that are
actually there to train our conscripts
have actually been deployed to Ukraine
so there's actually no one to train the
new people but the bottom line is that
actually in Moscow in Russia no one has
noticed and no one cares now that's uh
and as we know they've lost
um last I heard Brazilian was from
zielinski with six Mike just said nine
thousand square kilometers uh we have to
bear in mind that overall the Russians
have taken about 120 depending on how
you count it but like they were
currently occupy about 21 just before
the Holocaust front collapsed and that's
roughly speaking about 120 130 000
square kilometers of territory so in the
ground scheme of things they've maybe
lost you know
um 80 of that and none of it was
actually particularly Grand that they
were actually planning to keep and they
were I think suddenly planning to
negotiate away their gains in
hardcopopolis what they really want is
Don bass and what they really want is
the mariopol corridor that links uh
Crimea to donbass and the indications
are that they're actually planning to
negotiate away here so on but the
ukrainians may do that for them by
taking it first and so Mike's still
still an uphill battle then for Ukraine
from here
yeah I like it's not gonna end before
winter but um I think it's definitely on
the table that the war might end next
summer
um I remember coming on Spectators TV
about six months ago and you read out
one of my tweets that said uh I'm gonna
call this Ukraine's gonna win it and
that will be followed by the end of
Putin in Russia and I still think that's
the case I think the fundamentals are
that you know the three most important
things of warfare in Warfare a strategy
Logistics and morale and on all those
three scores Ukraine is doing much
better and is in the ascendancy and
Russia is the opposite and it is in is
descending on those on those criteria
um it there are some key questions right
at the moment that the route of the
Russian forces in the Northeast are they
going to be able to stabilize that front
line they've tried to do it behind a
river called the river or school
um I think that's been breached in a
couple of places so that's a big
question where they stabilize the front
line and then the second question the
immediate question is whether the
ukrainians have got a reserve with which
they can sustain that attack if not I
think nothing's going to happen before
winter winter is going to be you know a
naturally military activity dies down in
Winter Logistics are much more difficult
so on and so forth and then we're
looking at next spring and assuming the
ukrainians are going to use the winter
to train up rearm you know generate a
reserve then I expect to see another
offensive from the ukrainians and you
know to date they've been much more
agile than the Russians have been on the
battlefield and that's been you know one
of the key advantages that they've had
over the Russians Owen I want to come to
you very shortly about Putin's domestic
situation
um but before I do that you know one
question I always have when we're
talking about the situation on the front
line is how much we can believe what's
coming out of the Ukrainian government
because obviously you know this is a
side of the West is supporting but we
have seen that the government has picked
up for obvious reasons for morale
reasons uh successes so when reporting
or when analyzing a situation
what what how do you decipher uh what's
to be relied on what's not
uh well the answer to that is pretty
simple you just
um follow the pro Russian bloggers and
uh people on Twitter so there's actually
um and very interestingly there's
actually um several Rebel commanders
from the Don bass who have actually been
very vocal one of them is called
Alexander hodakovski not to be confused
with Mikhail hodorkovski
um and igusted in a various sort of
commanders are on the ground or still
covers not on the ground but he was
Former Defense Minister of the DNR and
they are constantly posting I don't know
where they get them but constantly
posting these uh uh Drone footage and
Battlefield footage and you know the you
know the uh you know headcam footage
because it's become you know it's it's
very much a sort of GoPro war and also
there's a lot of
um of official Russian correspondence on
the ground and also various sort of uh
Wing nuts including Graham Phillips our
very own British wing nut who's out
there
um who uh you know who is producing some
you know um I'm not incredibly reliable
information but certainly some
information in in an interesting metrics
on the ground about you know what the
soldiers are saying and so on and the
really interesting thing is that lots of
the supposedly pro-russian uh commanders
and Don bass have actually just been
saying you know we were betrayed we
haven't got the logistics you know
there's actually a lot of discontent and
anger and one of the points about my
article is that actually you know these
people who are currently you know hand
and fist with fighting on the ground
with the Russian forces are actually in
a very scary people there's a lot of
very extreme right-wingers among them
there's lots of extreme nationalists
among them and um
um right now they um the fact that
already they're speaking out and you
know Kremlin TV you know state-sponsored
TV
correspondence to speaking out is also
is actually quite significant it means
that things are really bad so it doesn't
really um you know necessarily confirm
everything that the ukrainians are
saying and I think the ukrainians are
actually slightly prone to exaggeration
especially if you look at the Ukrainian
defense Ministry Like official ticker
um and I think it's like 49 700 or
something was the last thing of you know
Russian deaths on the ground I mean I
suspect that's a little bit exaggerated
but nonetheless I mean the
um what they're generally saying about a
breakthrough is undoubtedly true
well Evan let's look at pictures
situation then because
um as you as you mentioned so far uh he
seems to have made some kind of
Coalition an informal Coalition with the
ultra nationalists and actually you
write that as these Ultra nationalists
who could be causing him more headache
now than the Liberals like Alexia
navalny that we in the west know so much
about
yeah the the Liberals are not a headache
they're not even like you know they're
they're not even the sort of you know a
vague thought in the in the minds of the
Kremlin they they're actually not
serious as a an opposition and certainly
there is 0.0 chance that they the
liberal opposition will succeed Putin
that is literally not going to happen I
mean and actually for instance the last
time that Alexander van needs who's very
often described on the BBC and so on as
you know the head of the Russian
opposition when they've only lost
actually stood for public election a
public office as a local Deputy in
Moscow we actually stood for mayor of
Moscow
um back in the early 2010s in 2011 I
think it was he received 20 and I've
only got 20 of the vote in Moscow so
that gives you a sense of how
electorally insignificant they are even
you know in his power base he gets 20 no
so the much more scary thing and it's
not necessarily an electoral threat but
it's the fact that these people are
armed motivated and highly angry
potentially the Kremlin and will become
more so if there is you know Battlefield
defeat are the ultra Nationalist
paramilitaries and um what's really
scary and I think that the point we
really need to to emphasize is the
threat is not that these people are
going to seize power I mean it's
possible it might seems power the
Bolshevik sees power with just a few
thousand people in in October 1917. so
it's not they're going to seize power
it's what the Kremlin and the people
around Putin are going to do to prevent
them from becoming a threat is the
vector in which the Kremlin has to go in
order to appease these angry nationalist
people and that is the real there's a
real threat so Mike actually mentioned
you know Russia about Putin and I think
a lot of people especially Western
capitals certainly in Emmanuel macron
um I know for a fact because I've spoken
to one of his advisors at some length
about this
um are actually rather scared about what
Russia without Putin will look like and
equally the the the the direct extension
of that is they're scared of giving
Ukraine too many weapons and two and
weapons that are too powerful and just
to give you a very precise idea of how
few weapons Ukraine is getting
um I'm not sure what the exact suddenly
like a few weeks ago they were operating
with 24 High Mars multiple rocket
systems that uh that launch high
accuracy Rockets 24 is what the
Americans gave the ukrainians in May the
Polish Army ordered 500.
so 500 high miles is what like a
medium-sized European Army requires for
its operational needs in peacetime 500.
the ukrainians have been given 24 in
Wartime so that really shows how
incredibly limited the military support
really has been and how and the reason
for that is because they're scared of
actually inflating a catastrophic
Battlefield defeat because they don't
want to cause another Russian Revolution
that's a real concern I mean it's
fascinating what you say about macron's
advisor telling you about this Weimar
Republic comparison because of course it
was post-war post first world war
Germany that led to Hitler
um it was fascinating calculus going on
here Mike what happens if Putin feels
like he has been cornered on the
battlefield because there is a lot of
talk about possibly is this when he uh
turns towards what's called a tactical
nuclear attack you know could that
happen
I so I think that there is a lot of talk
about that
um I think the thing about tactical
nuclear weapons is is there's no such
thing right all all nuclear weapons are
strategic and if your opponent loses and
uses a nuclear weapon you don't go oh
it's just a small one so that's why
they're all they're all nuclear weapons
um
for a long time now since the second
world war we've we collectively you know
the Russians the the nuclear Powers have
operated under these Norms of non-use of
tactical uh tattoo you got me doing it
of nuclear weapons and we do that
because of mutually assured destruction
right if somebody uses them then
somebody else is going to gonna deliver
a response my reading of the situation
is that uh a Putin doesn't know if he
uses a nuclear weapon what the response
will be there's three nuclear Powers
working against him France Britain and
America I'm sure there's a lot of
conversations under the table that we're
not aware of but the use of a nuclear
weapon on what is effectively European
soil I simply don't see how America
Britain and France can allow that to
stand so I think the calculation in
Putin's head will be well if I use a
nuclear weapon I can't be sure at all
that I Will Survive that use of that
nuclear weapon in terms of retaliation
or whether or whether you know bits of
Russia will also not survive and I I
think certainly he would be ejected from
Power if not killed in some way and I I
just think that that's his calculation
they are losing the war slowly and it's
hard to see how a nuclear weapon helps
them win that war and we haven't even
seen the use of chemical weapons for
instance which you know we saw Assad you
know Russia closed captioning not
available
and finally Sweden's social Democrats
have conceded defeat after losing this
week's general election one of the
parties in the new governing Bloc the
Sweden Democrats have been labeled as
far right by a lot of the English
language press are they correct and
what's behind the Sweden Democrats rise
journalist Paulina writes about the
election in this week's magazine and she
joins me now alongside the journalist
and founder of the new site the local
Europe James Savage both join me from
Stockholm
Paulina neuding and James Savage thank
you so much for joining spectator TV now
Paulina can you start by telling us what
is the latest with the Swedish election
because the vote's been counted now but
the government hasn't been formed yet is
that right
so what we know is that the new
right-wing block have
176 seats in Parliament to 173 for the
left-wing block we still don't know
what's going to happen because it
depends on negotiations within the
right-wing block and it depends on
whether
every single MP of that block indeed
votes in favor of it
um there might be some members of
parliament mainly within the liberal
party that might find that this goes
against their conscience so we'll see
you mentioned conscience there because
one of the reasons this election has
been quite controversial is that the
Sweden Democrats have been have done so
well and if you read uh English language
coverage the words far right or outright
or extreme right often come up so tell
us about the Sweden Democrats then
so the Sweden Democrats uh they're both
more problematic than similar movements
in Europe and and less problematic in
some ways than you might have been told
um the the tragedy of the Swedish cases
that all European countries have these
movements uh but the SD they do have the
roots in Neo-Nazi uh circles in the
right-wing extremism
um so you would have a skinheads at
their meetings that that was the kind of
company they kept on the other hand
luckily a lot has happened in the SD in
the past 20 years it has a lot to
distance itself from from its old
circles uh it has excluded masses of
members by now
um including its own youth wing
so it it started a new youth wing and
distance itself from the old one so if
you look at the party program today this
is typical Scandinavian kind
um
the anti-immigration populism rather
than authoritarian nationalism of the
Hungarian or polish kind so so this is
this is a good thing A lot has happened
in the past 20 years luckily
James let me bring you in here what do
you think do you think the Sweden
Democrats are far right
I would still class them as far right I
would say that they're not extreme right
I would draw the distinction there
they're not extreme right they are
certainly not um Nazi as you know
perhaps some of their very early
Founders were I mean they had they had
even people who who served in the vaffin
SS as Volunteers in their very early
years it's not that kind of party any
longer but I would say it is on the
Farah I think the nearest comparison you
could come with
um is um the um
in France Le Pen's party they've done a
fairly similar Journey from a very kind
of uh from from a very from an extreme
position perhaps to a much more
um to much closer to the to to the
mainstream right
but they still have far right elements
and I think you know what what um
Paulina was saying to us about their
history
um
but also about
um their um about their representatives
and what their representatives say it's
more that that classes them as far right
than their actual policy program you
have a lot of portentous gloom-filled
rhetoric I mean you know yumiorkis on
the leader uh accuses the quote-unquote
establishment of the other seven parties
of having destroyed our country and then
you have routinely sort of as an
anti-islamic statements and their party
secretary recently described um Islam as
an abominable religion that's inherently
violent and then anti-media so their
Chief of Staff Linus biland
um said that large parts of the media
are the enemies of the nation it's this
kind of rhetoric that I think sets them
apart from uh from mainstream parters
but James Paulina did say that they are
she would consider them as popular so in
your mind do you think populism and far
right those labels are equivalent
no I mean I think you can be populist
without being far right but I I but I
would I would say also that the the
Sweden Democrats are very much far right
populists and
um and you know that's very much their
um
that's very much the the kind of
politics that they that they believe in
and I think if you look at
of course when you get into semantics
it's always difficult but if you look at
the if you look at the um how the
Western media the English language media
refers for instance to um to Le Pen's
party financial times times
um uh the guardian they'll refer to them
as far as a far rights party and I think
that the that that the Sweden Democrats
are a very similar kind of party and I
think it therefore justifies a similar
kind of
um uh description well you're right
James that it is all quite semantic but
I do think that these labels are quite
important because far right has a very
very you know in some quarters a very
very pejorative
um a connotation so Paulina what would
you say about James then
uh I don't agree that they have a lot in
common with the national front in um in
France they are definitely to the right
of the Sweden Democrats again this is a
Scandinavian kind of populism and I
think a lot of
foreign observers would be surprised to
learn how uh liberal they are on life
stylishes I'm not saying they're
liberals they definitely aren't but this
is a Scandinavian kind of uh
anti-establishment populism it's very
distinctly Scandinavian in certain ways
the Sweden Democrats have tried for
years to be allowed into the pride uh
Pride celebrations for instance they've
been denied denied that but uh it's it's
um
yeah it's Scandinavian in that sense uh
which sets them apart from the formation
and many other uh movements on the
European continent and when it comes to
the issue of
of destroying the country
uh when you look at the uh Swedish
electorate and you ask people are you
pessimistic or optimistic about Sweden
and what's what's happened to Sweden in
the last few years one of the big
changes in Sweden is how
um how Darkly people view
Sweden and what's happened in Sweden for
for the past few years and that's not
very surprising giving given the state
of crime in Sweden crime is rampant it's
a it's a huge issue in the Swedish
society and it's for the first time it
was uh the top priority of Voters ahead
of the election so uh reality has has
helped the Sweden Democrats
unfortunately
Paulina can you give all
Ison indeed non-swedish viewers a taste
of just how bad the crime epidemic in
Sweden is
Sweden has the highest levels of gun
crime deadly gun violence and among at
least 22 European countries
um probably the highest in Europe
um and it's not just the shootings it's
not the sorry it's not just the fact
that shootings increasingly take place
in the broad daylight and without any
concern for for bystanders children
we're adults it's also uh bombings for
us we've had at least 500 or almost 500
bombings uh since 2018 which was the
year of the last election
um and some are I mean
some of these blasts have been enormous
residential buildings that have been
targeted with very powerful explosives
and this is part of the of the Swedish
gang scene the wars between gangs and
extortion that kind of thing so this and
this has no equivalent anywhere else so
record level deadly shootings bombings
which have no equivalent anywhere else
in the West
uh we have 60 immigrant majority areas
where the police say
that local gangs street gangs Clans Etc
compete with the state for local
Authority
um and at times these areas are
impossible for the Postal Service
ambulance drivers
the ice cream truck Etc to enter not
everywhere not always but at times and
that's very very serious
symptoms
and as the violence mainly happening in
these immigrant neighborhoods is that
what you're saying
uh they have been become hotbeds for for
gang crime yes uh and uh
so so there's a a very obvious link to
immigration
James I mean this is a link that the
Sweden Democrats have made what do you
make of it
yeah and they've made it very
successfully and uh I think there is a
lot of soul-searching now among the
traditional mainstream parties in Sweden
about the fact that they failed to react
to this quickly enough I think you know
they were very keen not to be seen to be
pointing the fingers at immigrants
obviously most immigrants are not um are
not committing gun crimes in fact most
most of the victims of these gun crimes
are in are immigrants themselves it's
happening in the areas in which they
live but these classes yes yes
and and I think these parties were very
anxious not to be seen to be pointing
the finger at immigrants and not to be
drawing the link between immigration and
crime and
um I think that they are now paying the
price for that in the rise of the Sweden
Democrats I'm not saying that if they'd
acknowledged this that the Sweden
Democrats wouldn't have got bigger I
think they might have done that anyway
but I think they might not have got as
big as they did if particularly the
party's on the center right but even the
social Democrats on the center left had
acknowledge the problem and taken
serious action earlier because they're
all doing that now they're all they're
all agreed that serious action is needed
they're all they're all they're all
they're competing with each other to
come up with
um you know more more Draconian measures
um to deal with the problems in these
areas
um but the Sweden Democrats are stolen a
March and I mean if you look if you look
at the polls and see who who has the um
the voters trust in areas of um of crime
and of immigration
it's the Sweden Democrats that come out
of so the other parties have um have
allowed them a free ride for far too
long and it's really really hard if not
impossible for them to catch up now and
that's the thing I mean Sweden has had
an extreme immigration policy we took in
more immigrants per capita during the
2015 migration wave than any other
country in Europe
uh Sweden has the the foreign-born
population has doubled since in the past
20 years to to 20 percent
uh where
um and and throughout uh during the
during all this time there was no uh
popular support for this kind of policy
and um uh what the established parties
did was to say that either you have it
our way or you're a racist
and the liberal party in 2004 for
instance they had posters saying yes to
immigration no to racism so those were
the two options and so
so the established parties formed this
cartel on immigration saying this is
what we're going to do and it doesn't
matter that people are against this
because that makes them racist
and so they effectively turned people
towards the Sweden Democrats and people
now Vote for This movement even though
the Swedish electorate is quite liberal
I mean it's it's definitely not even if
you you think of the Swing Democrats as
extreme right the Swedish electorate
isn't extreme right
uh so this was a huge mistake uh by The
Establishment by the established party
well James it does sound like what the
Sweden Democrats are saying and have
been saying alone for a long time is for
good reason
um breaking through so that you know
they're not they're doing something
right not just strategically but they're
doing something democratically right in
the sense that they're giving voice to a
concern that a lot of the mainstream
parties hadn't done
and that's why they're winning that's
why they're doing so well I mean I I
don't think there's any there's no
denying that
um what I would say is that
um
that doesn't change their nature as a
party you know they they it doesn't
change it doesn't doesn't change their
Roots it doesn't change some of the um
fundamental beliefs that the party has I
mean
the party describes itself as a
nationalist party it is a nationalist
Party by its own
um by its own admission it is not a
party of the center right
um have to be extreme you know we've got
a Scottish national party you've got
National first parties right okay yeah
nonetheless this is this is they are
they are also they are a right-wing
nationalist party and I'm not going to
sit here and defend the Scottish
nationalists either
um that's no I'm not here to do that
um but what I but what uh
but they are a nationalist party and
they are a party of the right and they
are a they are a party of the far right
and they're rhetoric and their history
says that I don't think it should be
particularly controversial to say that
what are they are they center right
they're certainly not center right are
they populist yes they're populist but
they are also on the far right of
Swedish politics and they are comparable
to parties
routinely described as being on the far
right in other European countries there
is very little I would argue I disagree
with Paulina about
um about the national France I think the
national fronts and the Sweden Democrats
have done a very very similar may have
made a very very similar Journey
um from a sort of
quasi-nazi past
um to a um to a to a
new kind of far-right politics
um that's that's now that that we're now
seeing in Sweden and in France
okay well James and Paulina we're gonna
have to leave it there but it's a
fascinating discussion and Paulina as
you mentioned in your article the Sweden
Democrats might not decide to go into
government because it might not be good
for them anyway so we'll keep an eye out
on that story thanks for joining
spectator TV
that's it for this week before we leave
don't forget that we've got a special
offer for spectator TV viewers for just
one pound you can get 10 weeks of The
Spectator in print and online just go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash sale to
sign up and don't forget to subscribe to
The Spectators YouTube channel as well
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss an episode thanks
again for watching and do join us next
week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]